Anthony was there any moment where you
felt spare change was not going to get
me where there are some close calls
where like sting might not be happening
there was only one day we we're in a
shooting in a building on downtown LA in
a loft space and we got all the specific
permits that we needed everything that
they told us we needed to do cleared
with the building manager but we didn't
clear it with the building owners
apparently and something was very weird
and I was someone I'm someone that's
like just do it and ask for forgiveness
later but we had the like we had to shut
down on our I think that was day three
we had to shut down like that's when you
kind of hit your groove because we were
in the same location for the first six
days shooting in this loft space so we
were right in the middle of that
everyone was finally getting comfortable
with each other so we had to shut down
for one full day which sucked and we had
to kind of do and this we were filming
right around the holidays we're like if
we don't get it in now we're gonna have
to do a pickup day after Christmas
because people are traveling and we
already just booked them for these
amount of days so write that in there is
kind of scary but then it was like all
right we ramped we figured out how to
condense everything and you know people
like I said got some great people on
there they were willing to work 12 hour
days 14 hour days to get it done so that
was the only like touchable the real
hurdle everything else was everything
else kind of went according to plan it
was it was nice yeah like everyone
worked really well together things
bringing in the right people no one
there were no I don't want to say this
the wrong way to say like shouldn't
bring in Outsiders that you don't know
but everyone had us the connector by the
way coolest nickname ever but everyone
was kind of connected in one way shape
or form it was always like a referral
like oh I worked with this person on
this show I'll bring him in to be my
camera assistant if that's okay we're
like oh yeah I'm worked with you so I
trust your decision so everyone could go
down you're Kevin Bacon line and get
brought back to the front and say who's
worked with two pretty well yeah what
was your typical day like in the first
let's say a few weeks of pre-production
like what were you uh we arguing over
budget to figure out you know where
we're gonna make our who's going to get
paid up front and who's going to get
paid on the back end which is a school
you talk about when you're talking about
film which was right around the time we
were talking about casting because if we
had a bigger name that could only work
on this day or this day we'd have to
switch around the production schedule
and to be able to just kind of be
organized and keep everything in line
because it was like I said I handled the
talent and the script supervision and
went over those rewrites and then
Jonathan Arturo handled the whole
production with their crew and said
here's our quickest way to do this
here's our best way to do this how do we
take what you're doing and make this
work with in here it's like we got to
find a lead actress that's willing to
work you know 14 days 12 hour days you
know give up her weekends if when if she
has them right before the holidays and
you know an independent film can be
really hit or miss so just had to find
the right people really and it worked
out yeah it really worked out it was
Elise was actually a childhood friend
our childhood excuse me a friend of this
girl devon who worked on my first web
series with me the one that was talked
about in the $50,000 hypothetical and I
had never met her but Devon had already
all we talked about yeah can't speak
Devon had always talked about her but I
had never met her and then her agent
sent in Elise's tape and she was great
obviously but then I was like oh yeah
she's friends with Devin Devon's cool
she's obviously got to be cool she's
definitely not the cycle of her girl
group so we brought her in and she was
awesome and now she's all over the place
and doing fantastic so happy for ya
you